you looked absolutely incredible
really honestly just so incredible i
mean what how scary slash green was that
moment it was a total combination of
both
um i i really like to do things that
kind of make me a little uncomfortable
and so this was obviously that i'm not
i'm not that person that like cruises
around my house naked
ever so it was you know it was
it was scary and then it was an
all-female
set that day and so that was like very
everyone was just there like boosting me
up and making me feel great and
beautiful and and i'm so happy i get it
and a great message for your two
daughters too about empowerment and
beauty so i love you totally even my son
i was like okay that's the one i'm a
little bit nervous to tell that i'm
doing it because he's ten but you know
you need to know their scripture that's
exactly how i feel that's exactly how i
feel i know
i'm not good enough
all of these photos are terrible right
calm down hey
don't tell a woman to calm down we hate
that it's almost as bad as telling us
that we look tired you think that we
don't know that we're tired we're the
ones inside of our bodies i am so
excited for season two of the show love
the original love your version as well
what can we expect what can you tease if
anything what can we teach we know
nothing
about that
i think you know we have 20 episodes to
play with which on season one we had 10
episodes so we know that that
studio is behind us and they're just
going to be like letting us have even
more space to play you just said that
it's absolutely right we have an
in-person writer's room this year which
is really exciting will make a huge
difference in you know that first year
we're all getting to know each other and
we have like masks done and it's just a
little different of an experience so
this time i think it'll be be different
and and uh you know we're all like so
excited to come back that
i think it's just gonna you know have
that energy where i'm screen yeah good
vibes
like
oh my god
robin scherbatsky
i know you from the news oh
you're that carl she's a fan i have fans
last we had kobe appear which i
absolutely love what other alum would
you want to get to make an appearance
next i think that
as a character i connect the most to
josh radner's character
and we we had some very lovely email
exchanges
and so i'm i'm wanting him but i think
we want all of them
all of them it's hard to choose right
it's absolutely
[Music]